So, welcome back. So, let us start. So, we were discussing. So, the next. So, up till
now we have discussed one neural network architecture where you have the input image. So, let me
just make it here. So, let me go back. So, we have an input image here. So, we have the
input image and then we have the convolutional neural network and then output comes a class
level. So, there can be multiple class level. So, if there are let us say 1000 classes there
will be 1000 many outputs. So, this is called the image classification task. So, this is
the image classification task and this task you can say this is one of the basic tasks
and it can be useful for many, many obvious things you can say like what is this image
about like is it does it have a cat, does it have you know what kind of things does it
have and the image net challenge basically is all about that ok.
But these are not the only applications that you have with images ok. So, let me show some
more applications ok. So, the image classification application is what we have already discussed
ok. Now, the second application is what is called semantic segmentation ok. So, what
is semantic segmentation? So, suppose you have this left image as the input ok. What
do you want to do? You want to have suppose this is let us say some let us say 250 cross
250 images image ok this input image. Your output should be also a 250 cross 250 image
ok same size as the input image and each pixel should have a class level. So, earlier there
was only one class level for the entire image for semantic segmentation you have one class
level for every pixel ok. So, what can be the class level? So, for example, this can
be sky ok, this can be let us say grass ok, this can be cat ok and this can be let us
say trees or forest trees or forest something like this ok.
So, these are the class levels ok. So, class level remember is for every pixel ok. What
is the utility? You have seen for example, the biggest utility you may have seen already
is what is called a your autonomous driving task or different kind of tracking tasks etcetera
ok. There you will see that the entire image you want to know in general what are the things
that are present in different portions of the image. So, if you can 0 in on a particular.
So, once you have this particular level you can 0 in on a portion and then you have a
description of what is there in that part of image rather than the whole image ok. So,
this is the first thing ok. Now, second thing second task is what is called
the object detection task ok. So, what is this object detection task? Object detection task
is suppose now your image has more than one maybe in this particular case let us say three
ok different objects of interest ok. Two of them are dogs one of them is cat ok. What
do you want? You want two things. First you want to identify that there are two dogs and
one cat ok. Secondly you want what is called a bounding box ok bounding box like this.
You want a bounding box around each of these dogs and cats ok. So, then what is the output?
So, whatever input image you have you will have a list of objects ok list of objects
get the corresponding bounding box. So, this is going to be the output for object detection
ok. And finally, there is the problem of instance segmentation. So, what is the problem of instance
segmentation? It is same as object detection ok. So, you will have a list of objects, but
now instead of bounding boxes around the object you will actually have the pixels ok. So,
you can see here the actual pixels which will describe that object. So, you can in a sense
say that if you do the instance segmentation problem the object detection problem is basically
solved ok. So, this instance segmentation problem is a slightly more you can say like
a more nuanced version of the object detection problem ok. So, the question is can you use
convolutional neural networks to do these tasks also ok. So, these tasks as you can
see they are very important tasks right. So, how can you use convolutional neural networks
to actually do this task? So, first let us look at the semantic segmentation task ok.
Now what will you do? So, the first thing is that what you can say that you use a small
patch. So, for every pixel you have to classify a label ok. So, you take a pixel like this
ok and you take a image around this particular pixel ok. And then you design a convolutional
neural network which will predict a label ok. Now the question is what should be the
size? So, these are sometimes also called patches ok. So, you can see. So, the receptive
field or the patch. So, it is basically a portion of the image ok.
So, the first question that will come is what should be the size of this patch ok. Nobody
knows how much context do you need. So, clearly from this particular example you can see suppose
your patch size is very small there is no way for you to tell that this is part of a
cow ok, but this is actually part of a cow ok. So, you need the bigger context ok. So,
first of all you need the bigger context and you do not know what should be your patch
size. So, what should be the solution? The solution is that you have a CNN ok, you have
a CNN and then. So, here first of all. So, this particular slide it is proposing a solution
where you extract a very big patch and then you sort of classify ok. So, maybe in this
particular case this center pixel will be classified as cow. In this patch also center
pixel will be classified as cow, but in this patch the center pixel will be classified as
grass. Now what is the problem with this two problems?
One is you do not know what is the appropriate size of patch. Here you can see, but in a general
image how will you know what is the appropriate size of patch. So, that is the first problem.
The second problem is you see these patches have to be overlapping. So, for every patch
you have to run a CNN ok. So, that is wasteful because most of the patches are overlapping
with each other ok. So, what is a good solution? A good solution is that you pass the entire
image through a convolutional neural network. Get the output of the convolutional neural
network and then use this output. So, do not use the fully connected layer at the end.
Just use the convolutional neural network get the output and then after that you use
the fully connected neural network for each patch separately ok. So, that way your entire
CNN computation does not have to be repeated. Only the final layer computation has to be
repeated for every patch right. So, this is a much better architecture ok.
Now the question is can you use the existing CNN architecture? The answer is no, why not?
Because if you see the CNN architecture that we just designed for image classification those
architectures they reduce the size of the image a lot. So, maybe a 250 cross 250 image
comes to a 10 cross 10 images something like that right. Now then there is not enough information
to classify every pixel in the original neural network ok. So, what is the solution? Use
another CNN in which you do not use any stride or you do not use any pooling layer. So, then
the size will remain the same you use the appropriate padding then the size will remain
the same as the input size ok. What is the problem with that? The problem is that the
computational overhead will be a lot see 1 or 2 layers you can do computation at the
highest resolution, but if you have to do many many different layers let us say 10 layers
of computation at the highest resolution it will be a lot of overhead ok. So, what is
the solution? The solution is yeah. So, this is what I was saying. So, the solution is
that you do down sampling and then you do up sampling ok. So, what is this up sampling
idea? The up sampling idea is that instead. So, so first of all down sampling you can
use two techniques as I have mentioned either you can use a strided convolution or you can
use a pooling ok. Generally people use a normal convolution and then a pooling ok. Now the
question is what is this up sampling right. So, up sampling is simple it is the opposite
of pooling ok. So, it is the opposite of pooling that is every pixel you blow up let us say
into 4 more pixels ok and then you apply a convolution on these blown up image ok. So,
this architecture also there are some more things, but you may have heard about something
called the unit architecture ok. So, this is the architecture that is used this is somewhere
here that you have a down sampling and then you have a up sampling and there are some
more tricks like in unit which is that basically there are some training tricks which we are
not going into which is that basically every layer is you basically train a auto encoder
kind of network with the input layer and the output layer. So, the intermediate weights
they get trained ok, but the important thing is that you use this kind of a down sampling
and then up sampling architecture if you want to generate convolutional feature map at the
original image scale ok. So, this is the first thing that you do ok. So, and then after this
you use like prediction layer to predict the pixel width ok. So, this is the first thing
and you can get a semantic segmentation ok.
Now, the next problem that we discussed is the object detection problem right. So, object
detection problem is what that you have to predict two things ok. First is you have to
predict. So, you have to first of all predict multiple objects ok. Now, what are these multiple
objects? These multiple objects are localized in different parts of the image. There may
be overlap between these objects, the bounding boxes between the objects may overlap, but
largely they will be separated. Otherwise it does not make it is not possible for you
to detect two objects right, maybe one object can be inside another object that is possible
ok ok. So, now how do you do the how do you do this kind of object detection? Again, so
suppose you now have a convolutional backbone it is called a convolutional backbone which
is that you have done the down sampling and up sampling in the and you have generated
features for the original image at the scale that you have the at the scale of the original
image ok. Now, how can you do this object detection?
So, a simple solution is again you have a patch. So, you start with this x y ok, x y
is the upper left corner ok and you have height and width. So, you have x y height and width
that will give you a particular bounding box ok. So, you have x and y and height and width
and you have this bounding box ok. And now this particular bounding box defines
a patch ok, you take this patch and you classify like you you predict some classification ok
and most of these will not be classifying anything. So, if you take for the example in
this image just this particular bounding box it will say no object. So, in the classification
you have one option which is no object ok. So, it will not predict, but if it predict
some object ok then basically for example, in this particular case this bounding box
it will predict the cat ok. So, this way you can do object detection,
but what is the problem? There is a problem with this. What is the problem? The problem
is that the number of such bounding boxes is very very large ok. So, if you have to
do this the number of such bounding boxes becomes very very large ok. So, the question
come can we speed up this and how to speed it up? So, so basically so here another thing
I forgot to mention is that you see this now uses what is called a multitask loss which
is that how correctly are you able to predict the bounding box and once you are able to
predict the bounding box ok, how correctly are you able to predict the label. So, the
two are related. So, suppose you start with an initial bounding
box of something like this ok, you may want to change or predict a correction over the
bounding box ok. So, this is what is called the correction over the bounding box ok. So,
this is the first thing ok ok. Now, so now there are all these problems that are coming
ok. So, so so the problem is you will have many many different bounding boxes, you also
do not know what kind of bounding boxes to consider. So, for example, consider this particular
image for predicting the big duct you need a very big size bounding box ok. For detecting
each of this small ducts you need very very small size bounding box ok. So, this is also
another problem ok. So, what size bounding box do you use ok.
What is the solution to all these problems? So, many many different bounding boxes and
also many many different sizes of bounding boxes. The solution is what is called a region
proposal network ok. So, what happens? So, this particular network you simply train the
network using some bounding boxes of objects and non-objects ok. So, you just take some
objects. So, these 2 for example, are objects and these 2 are non-objects ok and your network
should simply be able to say whether a particular bounding box has an object or not ok and this
should be done very very fast ok. So, the region proposal network runs very very fast
and it does not consider all the bounding boxes. It takes the entire image feature as
input and predicts something like let us say top 200 2000 region proposals ok. So, there
are both deep learning based solutions and shallow solutions to that, but this. So, this
is the approach that instead of considering all bounding boxes you consider let us say
about 2000 different bounding boxes which have a high charge of getting a object ok ok.
So, now how does your architecture come then here? So, first of all you have the backbone
the CNN backbone which gives you this. So, this was so by the way these kind of architectures
are called RCNN or region CNN ok ok. So, there are basically different versions of it. So,
the first is that you take these region proposals ok and for each region proposal you run it
through a CNN and then predict the class label and the bounding box ok. So, this is called
the slow RCNN. So, this is one of the earlier RCNN architecture.
A better architecture is what is called a fast RCNN architecture which is that you have
a common convolutional bottleneck ok. Then you have a separate region proposal network
which proposes the regions ok regions of interest ok and then for each of these regions of interest
you again have another CNN through which you predict either you predict like something
like the object category and the bounding box ok. Note that the object category prediction
is a classification problem ok whereas, the bounding box prediction it is a regression
problem ok. So, it is not a classification problem because you have to predict some numbers
ok. So, you have to predict basically x y height and width ok you have to predict these
numbers ok. So, this is the other thing ok. There is an even faster network which what
it does is instead of having a separate you know region proposal it uses the output of
the same CNN backbone to actually first compute the region proposal and then compute the bounding
boxes ok. So, classification loss and bounding boxes and in between it is also it also does
what is called a region. So, the region proposal gives what is called
region of interest ok region of interest. So, these are as you can see these are some
of the regions of interest ok. The further classification and bounding box prediction
happens only on the regions of interest ok. So, yeah. So, and these also do what is called
the region of interest alignment ok or ROI pooling. These are the basically something
similar things ok and then what you can what you can get is the prediction ok.
And of course, if you use this kind of an architecture ok you can just add another neural
network on top of this. So, earlier you had only this portion of the neural network ok.
Now, you can add another this additional mask prediction neural network on top of the ROI
pooling layer which can basically predict these masks and perform the instant segmentation
task also ok. So, these are some of the some of the important applications of CNN. So,
you can do object detection and instant segmentation with mask RCNN which is. So, it gives very
good results and it is one of the state of the arts network.
The only problem with this mask RCNN network is that it is a bit slow. So, there are another
class of neural networks called YOLO neural networks which are also very popular. They
are slightly less accurate than this mask RCNN network, but they are much faster ok.
So, as you can see we can do a lot of different computer vision tasks using these different
kinds of CNN architecture ok. So, these are some of the references and I will stop and
take some questions.
How would we identify what should the kernel matrix for a given input is there any recommended
approach to proper kernel. So, the answer to this question is we do not need to right
you just need to identify the size of the kernel. So, what do you need to specify you
need to specify the size of the kernel, how many what is the width and the height and
that too for most applications if you simply use as a starting point the VGG network or
something like UNET if you are doing image scale prediction or if you are using even
something like ResNet one of the ResNet architecture this is very good ok.
So, what you can do is you can use that particular architecture and then you can simply fine
tune for your application ok. If you have to identify the kernel size I would say you
follow something like the VGG thing which is that you use 3 cross 3 convolution and
then you use two layers or three layers or four layers of 3 cross 3 convolution as you
want your receptive field size to change and you also have to specify the number of number
of output channels right every time input channels will be same as the number of input
channels, but the number of output channels you have to specify. So, that is basically
something like you can specify like a few 10s like maybe 20 30 how many ever features
you want to detect hope that answers the question, did not understand center pixel in manually
designed kernel ok. So, can I go back to my slide, can I show my slide.
Yeah. So, see so this image will make it clear right. So, whenever you are yeah maybe the
slide should come. So, whenever you are whenever you are overlaying so this is the kernel ok
this is the kernel whenever you are overlaying this kernel on top of a receptive field. So,
this is the receptive field now the center pixel of this receptive field is this pixel
the output will be predicted. So, every time you do a overlay only one output value is
produced by the convolution kernel right only one output value ok this particular output
value in this particular case is 2 you can do the computation. So, you multiply this
times minus 1 this times 1 this times 2 and so on and so forth ok.
Center pixel determines where in the output grid this particular pixel will be placed
ok. So, that is the center pixel. So, it is the center of the receptive field where the
output will be placed I hope this is clear. How is output calculated with the help of
the kernel I mean the mathematical matrix calculation is used yes. So, this particular
calculation we have already shown if you just this is very important to understand this
this is the convolution operation ok. It is very important to understand this computation
which is given I if there was one slide yeah in this slide it is given. So, you can just
do the computation and you will understand how. So, this is the convolution operation
ok ok. So, thank you very much yeah bye.